[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials it's naz perez and there's a
lot to take in when you watch a movie
the acting the music the story and
generally those are the things being
discussed when you leave the theater or
you turn off your tv but there is one
aspect of filmmaking that often gets
overlooked when discussing how good or
bad or powerful or weak a film is the
cinematography when done well this is
what can truly transport you to a new
world make you feel like you're sitting
in the battlefield with a soldier or in
a nightclub in the roaring 20s
or with will ferrell at the roxbury and
as is the case with many jobs in
hollywood it's been a male-dominated
profession but over the years and more
so in this day and age there have been
some amazing female cinematographers
doing top tier work that's why today we
are going to bring you the most
beautiful movies shot by women
creed you see this guy here staring back
at you
yeah that's your toughest opponent
every time you get into the ring that's
what you're going against
i believe that in boxing and i do
believe that in life okay
let's throw a jab in the jaw
all right under the gut
you know every time you punch this guy
what's he doing
start one back out that's right so
either you block it slip it or get out
of the way
so
i'll leave you two alone for a while
coming in with a hard right hook as our
first film on this list is 2015's sports
drama creed shot by cinematographer
maurice alberti this marks the seventh
installment in the rocky franchise and
is a sequel to 2006's rocky balboa this
one stars michael b jordan as adonis or
donny creed apollo creed's son who died
before donnie was born but boxing is in
donny's blood and he eventually seeks
out the training help of retired champ
rocky balboa with sylvester stallone
reprising the iconic role and also
writing all of his own scenes the film
which also includes tessa thompson and
felicia rashad in supporting roles
reunites jordan with writer and director
ryan coogler after working with him on
2013's fruitvale station and before
teaming up again for black panther in
2018 and landing her skills behind the
camera was french cinematographer
maurice alberti known for films like
2016's collateral beauty and 2008's the
wrestler the latter of which also made
this list maurice turned heads after
filming an entire two-round boxing match
as a single take at one point during
creed with no tricks or edits she later
said to the shot quote i think you don't
need to rely on movie editing to dictate
emotion
come on
[Applause]
the film was released on the 40th
anniversary of the opening scene in
1976's rocky and became a full circle
event when stallone was nominated for
the oscar for best supporting actor for
create his first nomination since the
original rocky the success of this
spin-off led to a sequel creed 2
released in 2018 to critical and
commercial success and creed 3 with
michael b jordan making his directorial
debut is scheduled for release late in
2022. and critics thought this certified
fresh installment was a knockout with
the consensus that creed brings the
rocky franchise off the mat for a
surprisingly effective seventh round
that extends the boxer saga in
interesting new directions while staying
true to its classic predecessor's roots
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
beams no not at all oh my god i love
this kitchen
thank you so much
she's not looking at me she's busy
she's not looking at me
no one ever looks at me
i want my mommy
oh baby jewel hey julie is every little
peanut under there okay
he's fine you're really gonna want to
clear your mind and maybe grab some
sunglasses for this next movie on the
list it is 2004's eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind shot by
cinematographer ellen kuras directed by
michelle gondry this film stars kate
winslet is clementine who after a
painful breakup undergoes a procedure to
erase memories of her former boyfriend
jim carrey's joel from her mind but when
he finds out about these extreme
measures she's taking to forget their
relationship joel undergoes the same
procedure and slowly starts to forget
the woman that he loved joining jim and
kate on this wild adventure is a stellar
ensemble cast that includes kirsten
duntz mark ruffalo elijah wood and tom
wilkinson it could have been even more
impressive because ellen pompeo and
tracy morgan were cast and even filmed
some stuff but their parts were
ultimately cut the film's unique visuals
came courtesy of cinematographer ellen
kuras an unprecedented three-time winner
of the best dramatic cinematography
award at the sundance film festival she
would go on to shoot write and direct
the betrayal in 2008 which was oscar
nominated for best documentary i can't
see anything that i don't like about you
but you're not a kid but you will
you know you will think of things and
i'll get bored with you and feel trapped
because that's what happens with me
okay
okay
okay
and joining her behind the scenes was
charlie kaufman writer of films like
adaptation and being john malkovich who
took home an oscar for best original
screenplay for this film eternal
sunshine has crept into cult-following
territory over the years and there have
been rumors of a potential television
series based on the film being in
development for some time now and while
that's not for sure what we can bank on
is the fact that critics love this
certified fresh flick with a consensus
that quote kauffman's smart imaginative
script and gondry's equally daring
directorial touch make this film a
twisty yet heartfelt look at
relationships and heartache the neon
demon true beauty
is the highest currency we have
now without it she would be nothing
i think you're wrong
excuse me
i said i think you're wrong
i'm sorry are you gonna tell me that
it's what's inside that counts yeah
that's exactly what i think from
sunshine to neon the next film on this
list that shines bright with its camera
work is 2016's neon demon shot by
cinematographer natasha breyer this
psychological horror film was directed
by nicholas winning refin and features
elle fanning in the lead role replacing
carrie mulligan who dropped out with
scheduling conflicts fanning plays
jessie an aspiring model who moves to la
after her 16th birthday to launch a
career but her fast success and strong
potential soon makes her the target of
ruthless competitors who are jealous of
the new blood plus she has to deal with
a seedy motel manager and a creepy
photographer and ends up developing a
much more sinister side which proves
useful in dealing with these roadblocks
fanning is joined by a supporting cast
that includes jenna malone christina
hendricks and keanu reeves yep that
keanu the movie was shot in
chronological order and filming took
place in and around la and the one
making the actual magic happen behind
the camera was argentinian
cinematographer natasha breyer
i can't sing i can't dance
i can't write
no real talent
but i'm pretty
and i can make money off pretty
known for films like 2019's honeyboy and
2014's the rover breyer brought a unique
approach to this project that included
smearing the lens with grease from her
own unwashed hair to get the right look
for a scene she went on to win best
cinematography awards from multiple
festivals and outlets including the
fright meter awards and danish film
awards and while the movie is coming in
rotten on the tomato meter critics like
candace frederick from real talk online
recognized briar's skills saying quote
the photography is stunning but the
story is a hot mess with an overall
consensus from critics that the neon
demon is seductively stylish but that
can't quite compensate for an
underdeveloped plot and thinly written
characters
mud bound it was somewhere over austria
made contact with a whole swarm of mr
smiths
i mean they was everywhere
took out my tail gun
co-pilot
big deal with god right there
so if he saved me i was gonna do
something good
we're gonna get down and dirty as we
heard toward the next film on this list
2017's mudbound shot by cinematographer
rachel morrison this historical drama
was directed and co-written by d reese
and is based on the 2008 hillary jordan
novel of the same name it stars carrie
mulligan and garrett headland with a
supporting cast that includes jonathan
banks jason clark and mary j blige the
film is set in the rural american south
during world war ii and follows two
families bound together by their shared
farmland of the mississippi delta but
the mcallen family city transplants not
prepared for the harsh life of farming
and the jackson family long-time
sharecroppers who've worked the land for
generations are pitted against each
other by the social hierarchy of the jim
crow south this is made even more
complicated when sons from both families
return home from the war having forged a
friendship mudbound was a big hit on the
awards show circuit and pulled in four
oscar nominations including best
cinematography where rachel morrison
became the first woman ever nominated in
the category morrison who got her start
shooting shows like the hills and
working on various oprah specials has
since made quite the name for herself
with this film and others like 2013's
fruitvale station and 2018's black
panther i mean not a bad resume
you know what you're absolutely right
we was overseas
they didn't make her she was the back
door
general patton put us on the front line
yes sir you know what we did
we kicked the hell out of headline new
jersey
well y'all that hope safest sound the
film was also nominated for best
supporting actress and best song both
for mary j blige and oscar's first and
best adapted screenplay for rhys who
became the first black woman to ever be
nominated in the category i mean now
this is a groundbreaking film critics
had plenty to praise in the certified
fresh gem with ao scott from the new
york times saying that morrison's
camerawork quote brings the soil the
flora and the weather to life in a way
that emphasizes the archaic elemental
power of the story while the overall
consensus from critics is that quote
mudbound offers a well-acted finely
detailed snapshot of american history
whose scenes of world class struggle
resonate far beyond their period setting
the wrestler you never did anything
wrong
you know
i used to try to
oh forget about you
i used to try to pretend that
you didn't exist
but i can't
you're my girl
you're my little you're my little girl
body slamming and subplexing its way
onto this list next is 2008 the wrestler
shot by cinematographer maurice alberti
directed by darren aronofsky this film
is about aging wrestler randy the ram
robinson played by mickey rourke who is
well past his prime but still trying to
make it happen on the pro wrestling
circuit but after taking a rather tense
beating in the ring he decides to hang
up his boots and ends up pursuing a
serious relationship with an aging
stripper played by marissa tomei he also
tries to reconnect with his estranged
daughter played by evan rachel wood but
finds himself missing the ring and
starts dreaming up a comeback realizing
that life in and out of the ring is a
struggle filming for the wrestler took
about 40 days in the winter of 2008
taking place mostly in new jersey and
new york with some scenes shot at the
2300 arena in philadelphia and doing the
heavy lifting behind the camera was
maurice alberti who picked up an
independent spirit award for best
cinematography for this film look at me
i don't want to see you
i don't want to hear you
i'm done
do you understand
done
get out
albert t was mostly working on
documentaries at the time but did do one
other feature film in 2008 the onion
movie which was co-written by robert d
siegel a former onion writer who also
happened to write this film as well i
mean talk about an odd pair of projects
the film is credited for revitalizing
the career of mickey rourke who nearly
lost out on the role to nicholas cage
for rourke was the perfect fit for the
part and the spandex and ended up
receiving a bunch of awards love
including an oscar nom for best actor
alongside marisa tomei who was nominated
for best supporting actress and critics
were ready to award this certified fresh
film with a championship ship belt with
a consensus that mickey roar gives a
performance for the ages in the wrestler
a richly affecting heart-wrenching yet
ultimately rewarding drama a quiet place
[Music]
no need to crank your volume for this
next movie i will be sure to speak nice
and loud for 2018's a quiet place shot
by cinematographer charlotta bruce
christensen this one was directed by
john krasinski who also stars alongside
his wife emily blunt and they even used
some of their real family photos in the
movie i mean isn't that sweet the film
is about a family in a post-apocalyptic
world that is forced to live in silence
to avoid deadly and mysterious creatures
that hunt using sound with the slightest
whisper or footstep potentially bringing
danger the family relies on sign
language and other means to communicate
of course things are made even more
complicated because blunt's character
evelyn is pregnant and about to give
birth i mean not the easiest time to
stay quiet in fact the movie only
contains about 25 lines of voice
dialogue with the first not coming until
nearly 40 minutes in so that made the
job of danish cinematographer charlotta
bruce christensen even more important
[Music]
kristensen is best known for her work on
2016's fences and the girl on the train
the latter of which also starred emily
blunt and she knocked out filming over
the course of just 36 days in upstate
new york during 2017. the result was a
film that became a massive success
pulling in 350 million dollars worldwide
and paving the way for a sequel a quiet
place too released in 2021 with
krazynski returning to direct and the
main cast coming back plus the additions
of cillian murphy and dishman hansu
interestingly the film was once
considered as a potential fourth
installment in the cloverfield franchise
but it was decided it would work better
as a standalone film and good thing
because it is well on its way to being
its own full-blown franchise and the
critics wouldn't mind seeing that with
the consensus that quote a quiet place
artfully plays on elemental fears with a
ruthlessly intelligent creature feature
that's as original as it is scary
mulan tell me your sisters not the cause
of this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next up on this list of the most
beautiful movies shot by women is 2020's
mulan shot by cinematographer mandy
walker in this film yifei lou stars as
mulan the eldest daughter of hua zhao as
her family and community face the threat
of northern invaders in china she defies
both tradition and the law by disguising
herself as a male warrior in order to
serve in the imperial army taking the
place and hoping to save her ailing
father this film is a live-action
adaptation of disney's 1988 animated
film of the same name which itself is
based on the chinese folklore story
ballad of mulan by the way ming na wen
the original voice of mulan in the
animated film and other projects makes
the cameo in this film as well and
bringing that animated classic to actual
life was australian cinematographer
mandy walker a one-time cinematographer
of the year at the hollywood film awards
she's best known for her work on such
projects as 2016's hidden figures and
nicole kidman's australia in 2008 and
filming mulan was a global effort for
walker beginning in august of 2018 with
stops in places like new zealand and
china among others before rapping in
late november i can't believe all this
time you've been keeping your skill a
secret
what else have you been hiding
nothing
leave me alone
audrey we started off on the wrong foot
can we be friends
i'm not your friend
very well
but you are my equal
we fight together against the same enemy
i will do all i can to protect the
others this film was directed by nikki
cairo known for movies like 2015's
mcfarland usa and 2017's the zookeeper's
wife and it marked just a second disney
film with a budget above 100 million
dollars to have a female director
following ava duvernay's wrinkle in time
in 2018. with a scheduled release in
march of 2020 that was forced to be
canceled this film was one of the
biggest casualties of the coven 19
shutdown at the box office it was
eventually released in september on
disney plus for a premium fee with oscar
noms for costume design and visual
effects the consensus from critics was
that this film could have told its
classic story with greater depth but the
live-action mulan is a visual marvel
that serves as a stirring update to its
animated predecessor the little hours
did he just smile at you i don't know
why is he smiling who is that i don't
know who the [ __ ] are you
where are you
hernandez stop he's an intruder i don't
know who the [ __ ] he is let me get
mother maria fine go
tell me who you are
what
say something
where did you come from
what is that what are you doing with
your hands
what
what are you hungry what is that a bird
you're praying bringing a big cast and
sprawling scenery onto this list is
2017's the little hour shot by
cinematographer kuyan tran this black
comedy was written and directed by jeff
baina and is loosely based on the de
cameron a collection of novellas by 14th
century italian writer giovanni
boccaccio bayna only wrote a detailed
outline for the film and let the cast
improvise their way through it which can
work when you have an ensemble cast that
includes allison brie dave franco kate
mccucci aubry plaza john c reilly molly
shannon paul reiser adam paley nick
offerman and fred armisen i mean that is
a lot the plot follows three medieval
nuns leading a simple life in their
convent until they are joined by a
handsome young servant forced into
hiding by his angry lord poorly posing
as a deaf mute to discourage temptation
among the nuns but eventually all of
them end up going after the young man in
their own ways these are serious sins
and
do you regret doing these things i've
learned my lesson i really have and i
just i don't want to be that person
anymore if i go back on the road they
will catch me and they will kill me
well
i'll give you your penance
i want you to say 10 hail marys yeah
and 15 are fathers yes working behind
the camera with cinematographer kuyan
tran relatively new to bigger budget
projects at the time and who would go on
to shoot films like palm springs in 2020
and made in 2021 her canvas for this
film was the sprawling hills of the
tuscan province of luca outside of
florence italy and it proved to be a
unique backdrop for an ensemble comedy
and critics enjoyed the hours they spent
watching the little hours like sara
michelle fetters from moviefreak.com who
said vayner orchestrates events with
confidence and flair allowing his
amazingly talented cast room to frolic
and the overall consensus from critics
is that the little hours gets plenty of
goofy mileage out of its gifted ensemble
anchoring its revolved laughs in a
period comedy with some surprisingly
timely subtext
13. i mean they called the end of
slavery jubilee we thought we were done
then
and then you had 100 years of jim crow
terror and lynching
dr king these guys come on the scene
ella joe baker fannie lou hamer we get
the bills passed to vote
and then they break out the handcuffs
label you felon you can't vote or get a
job and now the ninth film we're going
to discuss from this list is 2016's 13th
shot by cinematographer kira kelly this
documentary was directed by ava duvernay
and is titled after the 13th amendment
to the constitution which was adopted in
1865 and abolished slavery throughout
the united states in this film durenay
explores the history of racial
inequality in the united states with the
idea that slavery has been perpetuated
since the end of the civil war she
explores the suppression of african
americans by things like
disenfranchisement lynchings and how
politicians declared a war on drugs that
weighs more heavily in minority
communities the doc also looks at the
prison system from once enabling police
to arrest poor free men and forcing them
to work for the state under convict
leasing to the emerging detention
industrial complex and how much money is
being made by corporations from these
incarcerations duvernay turned to a
familiar face to work behind the camera
and cinematographer kira kelly now kelly
has worked on duvernay series queen
sugar is part of a resume that also
includes issa rae's series insecure as
well as landing her camera op skills to
2021 chung chi and the legend of the ten
rings in many ways the so-called war on
drugs was a war on
communities of color a war on black
communities the war on latino
communities duvernay and kelly put forth
an eye-opening film that earned an
academy award nomination for best
documentary and won the prime time emmy
award for outstanding documentary or
non-fiction special and critics praised
13th as well with nell minau from the
alliance of women film journalists
saying that this fierce and fearless
documentary is so brilliantly
constructed that its message is
inspiring as well as infuriating with an
overall critic's consensus it says 13
strikes at the heart of america's
tangled racial history offering
observations as incendiary as they are
calmly controlled destroyer i'm not good
i'm the one who's bad
it's not you
all right
i'm sorry for lying to you and to finish
out this list of the most beautiful
movies shot by women is the 2018 crime
drama destroyer shot by cinematographer
julie kirkwood this one stars nicole
kidman as aaron bell former undercover
police officer who as a young cop
infiltrated a gang in the california
desert but with tragic results when the
leader of that gang suddenly reemerges
years later aaron begins seeking out
revenge against his former associates to
try and bring him to justice and make
peace with her tortured past the cast
also includes toby kebbel tatiana
maslany scoop mcnary bradley whitford
and sebastian stan but it was kidman who
took center stage despite battling the
flu during filming and she transformed
into a character so intense that kidman
said it took months to get it out of her
system along with director karen kusama
helping bring the story to the big
screen was cinematographer julie
kirkwood who turned heads with 2016's a
monster and has remained as relevant as
ever after shooting the pilot episode
for the hit showtime show yellowjackets
[Music]
only you
i know
i love you
destroyer hit theaters on christmas day
in 2018 and despite failing to recoup
its estimated 10 million budget at the
box office critics were into this
certified fresh flick sandra hall from
the sydney morning herald praised
kidman's collaboration with karen kusama
as another example of her willingness to
back a filmmaker still to pee and the
overall consensus with critics is that
the film's grueling narrative is as
uncompromising as kidman's central
performance which adds extra layers to a
challenging film that leaves a lingering
impact alright friends that is our list
of the most beautiful movies shot by
women be sure to check out these and
then go find some more there are a bunch
of great female cinematographers and
filmmakers out there putting forth some
amazing work thank you for checking out
rt essentials i'm naz perez and we'll
see you guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
you